welcome to hannity and breaking tonight
the state department has now at this
hour just issued a security alert
telling all americans in afghanistan to
immediately leave the gates surrounding
karzai international airport as the
situation now in afghanistan remains
dire thousands of americans and our
allies remain trapped behind enemy lines
the situation is deteriorating by the
hour
the taliban whether
we like it or not is in control
largely in control of the country
certainly in control of the city of
kabul i don't know why people and
everybody they are hiding they are
hiding the reality of the taliban i
wanted to encourage the president to
stay longer but he has to as i say weigh
the equities of the danger
versus the advantage and i trust his
judgment what are you telling those
americans and maybe they're not in kabul
but they're somewhere in afghanistan how
will they get out i'm in contact with my
friends i'm in contact with my family
and every one of us we are so worried
and we have no idea what will happen
after august 31st we are on the cusp
paris of having the biggest mass hostage
situation
in american history it's going to make
1979 and tehran look like a sleepover
how many individuals on terror watch
lists have been screened or found at any
of the screening points either
in qatar ramstein or in the u.s
i don't know if you believe we left
afghanistan we've ended the war between
the u.s and radical islam you're a fool
americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day 11.
americans held hostage beyond enemy
lines day 11 and yesterday the biden
administration they promised to give you
america an accurate number of how many
americans are still trapped but today no
such luck and depending on who you talk
to at the state department as many as 4
000 americans are still trying to get
out or according to anthony blinken it
could be 1500 plus or minus a few dozen
here and there in other words they still
have absolutely no idea not a clue now
this is critical information we need an
accurate count desperately any american
in afghanistan after august the 31st
that is this coming tuesday will be left
behind enemy lines and subjected or
subjugated to the whims of brutal
terrorists ostensibly yes they will be
hostages and today when one nbc reporter
asked biden what he will do if americans
are still in afghanistan after the
taliban's deadline that he said he
agreed to biden responded with a joke
you'll be the first person i call
you decide if it's funny
not particularly funny to me considering
how dire things have become the
president answered zero questions as per
usual doesn't want to get in trouble
after that and said nothing about the
crisis not one word in afghanistan he
had more important things to do by the
way like touting the five trillion
dollars in reckless spending instead of
being fully focused on fixing this mess
in afghanistan that he himself created
biden's secretary of state meanwhile
noted that there were no concrete plans
for evacuating people after august 31st
other than certain diplomatic efforts
and economic assistance hmm i wonder if
we call that ransom take a look
your question is there any concrete
steps oh yes i'm sorry but you can give
to people who are very worried right now
understandably about whether they're
just going to be forgotten left behind
disappeared once the united states
withdraws its military and can no longer
protect their safe passage to the
airport or you know their other
livelihoods
the short answer is
no
they will not be forgotten
and as i said
we will use
every diplomatic
economic
assistance tool at our disposal working
hand in hand with the international
community
all military will be gone so we have
diplomatic and economic assistance as
our tools to use to get americans free
if they're left behind in other words
the grand master plan post august the
31st let's beg and bribe the taliban pay
a ransom to release anyone still held
hostage behind enemy lines which is
pretty much what we're now doing except
after august the 31st our military will
be completely evacuated the airport will
be in total control of the taliban and
anyone left behind will have no way out
why because of joe biden our people our
fellow citizens quite literally will be
at the mercy of taliban terrorists biden
ignored one warning after another as the
country
literally collapsed before the world's
eyes multiple sources telling me tonight
the cia they pulled out six or seven
weeks ago and to their credit they were
telling joe biden exactly what was
happening on the ground they did not
mince words and by the way we are told
our sources so did the department of
defense joe biden completely ignored
them and the way he has been
characterizing it to you the american
people is completely at odds with the
intelligence that he was being given
look at your screen and those papers
will come out one day he ignored their
warnings look at may in afghanistan when
the taliban began their offensive he
ignored notice the red it starts to take
over then in june after the taliban took
control of dozens of provinces what
happened to this great afghan army that
joe biden was bragging about he ignored
their warnings in july look at the map
in july when the taliban controlled the
vast majority of the country and were on
the march we still had control of kabul
we could have seen what was happening
and acted immediately and we could have
logistically safely extracted every
american and our equipment which i'll
get to in a minute in fact just as the
taliban was closing in biden closed
bagram air base by the way the trump
plan would have kept that in our
possession and so by august it was too
late game over nor did he want to come
back from his vacation our embassy was
abandoned he stayed on vacation
thousands of additional american troops
had to be sent back to kabul even though
we saw this all coming just to secure
the airport which is now our only way
out of the country well there's one
problem with that the taliban they
control the entire perimeter of the
airport with all their checkpoints and
they alone decide who will get to the
airport but according to joe biden this
was always going to happen there was
never a way out that's not chaotic yes
there was his hands were tidy said and
he planned for every scenario that seems
to be a lie also
nothing could be further from the truth
this all could have been prevented
easily you don't have to take my words
for it just listen to president trump
this is way back in 2017. he ran on the
pledge that he wanted to get us out of
there as quickly as possible take a look
the consequences of a rapid exit
are both predictable
and unacceptable
911 the worst terrorist attack
in our history
was planned and directed from
afghanistan
because that country was ruled by a
government
that gave comfort and shelter to
terrorists
a hasty withdrawal
would create a vacuum that terrorists
including isis and al qaeda
would instantly fill
just as happened
before september 11th
remember not a single american was
killed in the last 18 months of the
trump presidency around 18 months and
that was even after he made the deal
with the taliban and guess what they
weren't on the march then because they
believed and feared donald trump
president trump was right in 2017 joe
biden was wrong and now thanks to
biden's half-baked withdrawal plan
thousands of people it's guaranteed at
this point they will sadly die afghans
that assisted us will die and americans
everywhere are less safe in less than
six days anyone left in afghanistan who
assisted the united states or the afghan
government along with their families
will be killed by the taliban it's
already happening according to reports
and america left behind the entire
database now in the taliban's possession
they will all be hunted down and when
they are caught they will be murdered
and joe biden is the person you can
blame and think about this many of them
will be murdered with the very weapons
that joe biden didn't make preparations
to bring home
or destroy at the very least i would
have brought them home a reported 83
billion dollars worth of weapons that
you paid for that includes get this
75 000 armored vehicles get this
208 blackhawk helicopters and other
aircraft 200 million dollars worth of
drones we gave them our drones
600 000 military-grade guns and other
weapons and let's not forget the
thousands of night vision goggles
uniforms bulletproof vests other
protective gear and then to top it off
the taliban even has access now to
biometrics data left behind that means
for any afghan or anyone that assisted
u.s forces over the past 20 years they
will be told look into this computer and
if there's a match that person will die
and then to top it all off al qaeda is
very much alive and well in spite of
what joe biden and others are saying in
afghanistan and they are working hand in
hand with their brothers in the taliban
they will likely have access to some of
these weapons and now a safe haven to
plan future attacks likely against us as
their number one target this is our
intel capabilities have been shattered
although in all credit to the cia in our
intelligence community they did warn
biden the cia pulled back according to
my sources and they warned
in great detail exactly what would
happen my understanding is there is a
paper trail now the people that will be
left there we will be left safe here at
home just 20 years after 9 11. operation
enduring freedom has now under joe biden
become operation tyranny and death but
joe biden doesn't seem to be bothered
thousands of americans our friends
hopelessly trapped behind enemy lines
and right now i guess as joe biden
sleeps ever so peacefully at the white
house not a care in the world hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else